YouTube is a place for people to share
their ideas
if by people you mean thirteen year old
girls and by ideas you mean how they
love the Jonas Brothers I'm just kidding
but let's be honest that's a hefty
majority that's true that's comedian and
director Bo Burnham one of you took
YouTube's first viral stars back in 2016
when he was just 16 Burnham began
posting videos of his satirical songs
from his bedroom he went on to perform
stand-up around the country star on his
own TV show and film for comedy specials
all by the time he was 27
now he's written and directed his first
feature film it's called eighth grade
it's inspired by his experiences growing
up and performing online the film
follows a 13-year old wannabe Utah
youtube star name is Kayla through her
last week of middle school including
fights with her dad at the dinner table
I think he was so I say one thing please
pine thank you look when I was your age
I was not cool like you
you have always interests and and your
videos and just how you express yourself
in them is so it's just so cool it's so
great and I just I just think maybe you
see to put yourself out there a little
bit please stop eighth grade is getting
rave reviews the Washington Post calls
it no perfect debut for the new
filmmaker his name is Bo Burnham he
joins us at the table bo thanks for
having me congratulate this movie I
can't tell you it's so so good and the
dad is trying so hard and I fell in love
with that little Lily's Fisher yeah but
it's told from her perspective and you
were a grown-ass man how old are you now
27 yes you're 27 so how were you able to
get into an eighth graders mind swell
what did you do I watched you know
hundreds of videos of kids online
talking about themselves the movie sort
of framed with her doing vlogs hey ki
guys it's Kayla yes and I was very
interested in kids expressing themselves
online
the the boys online tended to talk about
video games the girls talked about their
souls so I was like okay I'm probably
gonna write about a girl it's a little
more interesting yeah yeah the good
thing about this generation is if you
want to learn about them they are
posting everything about themselves
online so the research is
pretty quickly at hand but you said you
were a hammie loser boy so I'm wondering
if you're drawing that your words not
mine
yes were you drawing a hammie like I
wasn't sure my shyness and my anxiety
didn't really peak until I was sophomore
yeah but it's a loser boy part okay so
did you draw from personal experience at
all
I mean eighth grade wasn't ideal for me
my body was exploding and I was you know
terrified of everything yeah all the
time
but no I really wanted to talk about how
I was feeling living now and for me like
the culture is kind of going through an
eighth grade moment yeah I feel unsure
of myself weird strange maybe you wanted
to explore anxiety yeah I think it's
something that so many people know about
with their kids right yeah I think so
and it's just a very anxious time I
think for all of us it's not just time
now and and especially being an eighth
grader right now feels yeah as the
father of an eighth grader there were
moments in this where I had to run out
of the room maybe just to do just
spot-on thing also is at that great age
you're trying to figure out what your
identity is whether you add social media
or not you do little experiments and
tests you go away to camp in you're a
different person than when you come back
to school yeah but now it's all recorded
and the feedback is in real-time with
likes or no likes and the way in which
Kayla says you know she's not sure if
anybody's out there listening to her I
mean it is so acute so how does social
media basically make more acute what is
a natural thing that even you went
through and that all of us went through
but that's been yeah what I'm interested
in the movie is just really taking
inventory of it I'm just trying to
describe it there's so much commentary
in the current moment and so much
commentary about what kids are going
through and not enough descriptions the
movie itself is just trying to go you
know I don't know if social media is
making it worse or better you know it's
making them more connected and lonely
more stimulated more numb they can
express themselves or objectify
themselves and this movie is just trying
to express it honestly and maybe give
you the raw materials to have a
conversation and you use actually you
used actual eighth graders in the movie
tell us about some of the auditions for
that because they're not all actors yeah
a lot of them were just kids from the
actual school that we filmed that we
have faith graders I would go up every
Saturday when we before we're making the
movie and meet all the extras one by one
have a little conversation with them
I'd say you know what's your name give a
special talent one girl came up I said
what's your name she said her name I
said you have a special talent and she
said I have eczema another kid was
eating a bell pepper like an apple and a
oh you're so qualified you know how can
we get the kids into this movie
unprocess in the movie to one line you
have confidence is a choice just act it
even if you don't feel it you can't be
brave unless you're scared I love that
line yeah that's yeah I'm choosing to be
confident right now yeah how did you
direct though an eighth grader because
you don't wanna get in the way I well I
was warned a lot like you don't want to
work with kids like they're so so
difficult I found it to be the exact
opposite the adults were the ones that
were I was going I stand over here and
they're going is my light over here and
the kids are going I'm going spit in
your hand and the kids are going which
hand is so open and like ready to
imagine and be free so it was like super
incredible the movie is rated R right
yeah do you want eighth graders to see
it why should they see it and I saw that
common sense gave it four out of five
stars
yeah and 99 rotten tomatoes yeah yeah I
think you know I think it's a soft are
first of all eighth grade is rated R cuz
eighth grade is rated R yeah you know it
didn't feel like it was my
responsibility to try to portray a
reality that was appropriate for kids
it's all reality as a culture to create
a reality that's appropriate for kids I
promise you this movie is not exposing
your kids to anything they're not
already aware and I think you can
actually incentivize some good
conversations that might not happen on
you being able to channel an eighth
grade girl but it's the father's message
at the end how'd you do that you don't
have any 3d role yeah well you know I
feel like both of them I feel like a
scared kid on the internet and an
out-of-touch dude that has no idea
what's going on and you know there's
actually a lot of my mother and in what
he's saying at the end but I'm right
between them you know I'm 13 years
between them so I was able to sorta I
think
Bravo really good so timely really
appreciate it guys thank you everything
eighth grade is in select cities now and
will be in theaters nationwide on August
3rd